enough would help the charity basically
commissioned a healthy and launched a
healthy index a healthier index and they
had done a survey of 8 000 people to
find out about their mental and physical
well-being and the stats were quite
shocking really because they were saying
sort of like 60 of people's physical
health and 59 of people's mental health
were suffering because of the costs of
living crisis and following on I'm
following off the back of you know
several years of covid in which we all
we all would have grown down a little
bit yeah and it's very it's interesting
because some were saying like their
physical health is better because they
learned different things during the
pandemics if you think about it you know
some people went the whole I've got to
get out so I've got a walk I've got a
cycle I've got to run you know so all
these people that never did it before
but that's because we had time now we're
getting back into our busier Lifestyles
aren't we and what people are saying is
that it's having a huge impact on their
physical mental health but people aren't
looking at the correlation between the
both so five but five extra minutes yeah
I mean to be like that that doesn't
sound an awful lot given given that you
know I live my professional life in
15-minute chunks but but five minutes
can really have a have a ton around
effect for people Yeah because sometimes
it's just um mindset isn't it changing
so as you mentioned you know if you got
off the bus let's say at the stop before
the one you should have that's the quick
brisk walk you make a conscious decision
to change you know if you um are looking
even if you're looking online and taking
five minutes to see what can you do at
home to do exercise so there's so much
free resources online isn't there that
you can actually take that conscious
decision breathing techniques take five
minutes earlier of putting your phone
down before you go to bed you know all
things that are more healthier for you
are going to help you distress lose that
anxiety they're saying that we should
have and I I didn't even realize it's
that one between seven to nine hours of
sleep at night
but on average it's five hours and 54
minutes now if that's the average and
yet you're meant to be getting between
seven and nine and that's not good is it
and people are saying they're stressed
they can't sleep and sleep is a really
big thing and I'm bad at it myself so
there are little conscious things that
we can change and that actually only
takes five minutes to think about it it
it's making that first step though I
mean I I over the past couple of years
I've seen my physical health can go up
and down and clearly I'm clearly not a
Peak Physical Fitness again but I am
back in the gym and I am back in the
swimming pool but it was getting started
yeah that was the biggest issue for me I
mean given given your pedigree and given
the kind of sports psychology that you
the psychologist you will have worked up
with how do you how do you take that
first step how do you work up the
courage to start yourself on the road to
getting yourself slightly better I think
it is taking accountability of yourself
because most people's mental health will
suffer if their physical health isn't
good and vice versa so it's actually
making those conscious decisions to
change now if everybody knows when they
don't feel that great about themselves
whether that's physically or mentally
and actually you can go for a really
five minutes what you can make a
conscious decision instead of actually
watching the ads during a break of your
show get up and move you know going up
downstairs going out for that quick
extra walk kind of just moving the body
can have a big positive effect and then
also I'd say do things with people you
know socializing is really important
meet somebody at a park meet your best
mate and just take that time but I think
we're not taking that time anymore
because we've got back to our busy
Lifestyles and that's where you see the
stats starting to get worse and worse so
think about what you've done when you
felt brilliant what was it that makes
you feel good alive I went for a walk
this weekend with my mates you know
they've been friends
42 years you know and they we all live
close together and I'm thinking why
aren't we meeting up so I just text and
said I need friend time and I literally
said I need some friend time because I
was so stressed and anxious because I've
been so busy and I thought you know what
and you know it was the best thing I had
laughs we went for a walk and I felt so
good when I got back I was just ready
for my week again I see I I think some
people who have been listening to that
will Bull have been slightly shocked
that someone who has dealt with you know
professional sport at the level that you
were at
could even experience stress in in the
first place well I've had a lot of
mental health problems like I have and
I'm very open with it because you know
lifestyle's change and you know we go
through different parts of our life
where they have lots of impacts and
there's been times where
the adverse effect on my mental health
has actually given me
um the sense of I can't be bothered I'm
not motivated you know I just lethargic
and actually if I think about it I'm
thinking but that's what also makes me
good when I move so I have to take that
accountability of myself as well that
when I'm feeling low and I'm feeling
like frustrated the last thing you want
to do sometimes just want to wrap up and
stay indoors or stay in bed but actually
I know if I get myself up and going that
endorphins adrenaline will make me feel
better and happier so it is US looking
us at Lifestyles and going do you know
what I it's stressful anyway life is
stressful anyway for so many people we
all know that but if you could actually
go do you know what I am going to take
that five minutes from me and I don't
care it's non-negotiable to think about
yourself and to think about your health
and so I think we should all take that
into account I think we should but but
it's the idea I think that will be
refreshing for some people to hear you
don't need to go out and run a marathon
you don't need to be going to the gym
five days a week you don't need to be
doing kind of the level of training that
you obviously did when you when you were
at your Peak but five minutes and doing
something we've given us one example
getting off the bus to stop earlier give
us another couple okay so a lot of
people have stairs at home like going up
and down the stairs that gets your heart
rate up right but you can see how unfit
you are when you do it even once so you
could go up and down your stairs you can
do little step UPS on your stairs you
can go online there's so many free
examples of Fitness so core upper body
even with like tins or like your big
bottle two little bottles of water if
that's all you've got sit there on your
sofa using your arms pressing it up you
know you can you know what it is
some tricep dips off the end of the
bench no but there is lots
some people still have not had the
breakfast no but there are things and
when you say five minutes people say
five minutes can't make a difference if
you get your heart rate up for five
minutes more than you ever do
that will also then go into 10 and 15
because when you start to feel
firstly if you feel how unfit you are
sometimes that shocks people yeah so
then they make a conscious effort to do
it more and it's about consistency so
just very quickly um nuffield health.com
forward slash healthier Nation that's
got lots of free resources on that
website of how to keep how to change
Lifestyles how to do things positive for
yourself both nutritionally and
physically
wonderful to have you here this morning
wonderful to hear you speaking with such
excitement about you know something that
could can change people's change
people's minds and turn their lives
around a bit